and yet the insanity continues
usa today has an op-ed that i thought
was
satirical kovid has turned breathing
into a deadly event
and all of us into potential serial
killers that has to be satirical right
it's not if i hold my breath when i hug
my parents will that spare me the greek
tragedy of killing them
this mental toll will last long after
the threat fades there is a mental toll
here
and there is a true epidemic
that is psychological it's hysterics
like this man michael stern
absolute hysterics afraid of the flu
a very strong flu a coronavirus i guess
to be specific
a very strong one i'm not i'm not
downplaying that it's
strong and that that especially people
in certain groups are at risk for it
it's got a far greater than 99 survival
rate
people are referring to it as a plague
he refers to it as a plague it ain't the
plague
it's a virulent virus that has been with
us
now for a long time and it's going to be
with us for a very long time
and we were told millions and millions
of people were going to die from it and
thankfully that turned out not to be
true
this guy really believes that we're all
serial killers this is the political
problem by the way
which is that we are social creatures we
live in a body politic we need to
interact with one another we are not
meant to be alone there are a lot of
people who are dying right now alone in
nursing homes
dying of loneliness dying because
they've lost the will to live
because these psycho politicians and
hysterical opinion columnists
have made it such that we no longer view
our loved ones and our fellow citizens
as friends and loved ones we view them
as bags of germs who are out to kill us
and we're out to kill them
that is a far greater threat to the
public health and to society
than any virus could be certainly
than this virus